coming in texas senator ted cruz good to
have you sir um
excuse me uh kamala harris's appointment
to
take over the border leader mccarthy
over on the senate side he said that
vp harris is now the point person for
the biden border crisis
then senator harris when she was senator
compared ice to the kkk
introduced legislation to reduce
detention beds by 50
said cbp holding kids longer than 72
hours was inhumane
does she stand by all of that is his
question i'm sure you have questions too
but i also would ask you
should she be given a chance to do this
and see how she does
well i gotta say my reaction to that
appointment is is wow
joe biden really doesn't like kamala
harris
this border crisis is the biggest
political mess joe biden has
it threatens to derail the entire
administration so what does he do
he looks to his vice president and says
you take it it's your problem now
and and listen unfortunately she is not
going to be able to solve this crisis
why because they've created this crisis
and they've created this crisis
because of their political partisan
commitments
that they can't back away from so why
are we having this crisis at the border
because when joe biden got elected the
first thing he did was stop construction
of the border wall
he reinstituted catch and release and
the failed policy so that now when we
detain
illegal immigrants we let them go we
give them a court date sometime in the
future
and many of them never show up and he
ended the remain in mexico policy which
was this incredibly successful foreign
policy accomplishment
where the trump administration had
negotiated with mexico
that illegal immigrants from central
america would remain in mexico
while their asylum proceedings were
moving forward all of those
had produced real success but because
the democrats
campaign on saying ice is evil securing
the border is wrong because the
democrats
support open borders kamala harris
doesn't have anything to do other than
go down there and let everybody go i
mean that's the only
option that is consistent with the
political promises she's made
and i'll tell you representing the state
of texas we are seeing illegal
immigrants being released in harlingen
texas
the illegal immigrants they're releasing
are testing positive for covid 19
at a seven times higher rate than the
u.s population it is a humanitarian
crisis
it's a public health crisis and it's a
national security crisis they blame the
trump administration i'm sure you've
heard that already you're going there
tomorrow senator corden are you
your fellow uh texas senator when do you
think kamala harris goes
or president biden you know i have no
idea they asked kamala a few days ago
when she was
if she was going and she just laughed at
that that question i
actually tonight i'm headed down to the
border and i'm bringing 18 senators so
i'm i'm bringing
18 senators to go down to the border
we're going to the facilities we're
meeting with the border patrol we're
meeting with the border patrol union who
i know very well
uh we're going to inspect those
facilities and and see them directly
and and i'll tell you we invited fox
news to embed with us we invited abc
news to embed with us
and the biden administration has said
hell no
they will not allow reporters anywhere
near so they're blocking
when 18 senators show up the biden
administration is saying no reporter can
show up
because and this is their argument and
it really is laughable
they they say that reporters there's too
big a risk of covet
that that if there's a cameraman
suddenly
it's a coveted crisis never mind the
donna facility
which they won't allow reporters into
the donna facility
its capacity is 250 people it currently
has
nearly 4 000 people in it that is 1
500 percent in excess of its capacity
there's a reason they don't want
reporters in there it's not covid
the reason they don't want reporters in
there is because they don't want the
american people to realize the absolute
train wreck of a policy that the byte
administration is implementing
senator you can let them know we've been
working for a year non-stop
uh two more topics quickly david well i
wanted to ask you about the other thing
that's happening and this is a big deal
yesterday um
hr one which is uh the bill that the
democrats passed in the house to
basically
completely change voting rights in
america there was a hearing on it
yesterday
what do you think is the most important
thing for americans to know about that
bill
so i think this is the most single most
dangerous bill being considered by
congress right now
it is the corrupt politicians act
because it is designed
to entrench corrupt politicians in
office and to keep democrats in power
for a hundred years what does it do it
has the federal government take over all
elections
it repeals virtually all of the common
sense
state integrity laws for election
integrity so for example
29 states have voter id laws including
my home state of texas
the corrupt politicians act repeals
every one of them says it's illegal to
require identification to vote
the the corrupt politician act also
mandates universal mail-in voting
everywhere for no reason whatsoever and
it mandates ballot harvesting which
which 31 states have made illegal
that's paid political operatives that
say go to a nursing home and they
collect
hundreds of ballots and and it is it is
the single most likely circumstance for
voter fraud because those paid
operatives
that they can go to vulnerable seniors
in nursing homes who may not be in a
condition to make
choices if the seniors vote in a way
they don't like they can throw their
ballot away
and and the democrats are trying to
expand those opportunities for fraud
and i'll tell you even more
fundamentally than that dana what it
does is it automatically registers
anyone who interacts with the government
anyone who gets a welfare check an
unemployment check anyone who gets a
driver's license anyone who goes to a
public
university the democrats know that will
result in
millions of illegal immigrants being
registered to vote and that is their
objective is to get millions of illegal
immigrants to vote
and it also strikes down all the state
laws limiting
felons limiting criminals from voting
this law mandates that when anyone
leaves prison they can immediately vote
so so the democrats have decided
apparently what america needs is more
murderers more rapists more child
molesters voting
and they've made the very cynical
decision that millions of illegal
immigrants and millions of criminals
voting
is going to benefit democrats and keep
them in power this is a
very it got off the ground the house
we'll see whether or not it goes
anywhere in the senate quickly sir i
just want to play a clip from you
yesterday
on the hill you came out to talk to
reporters and this exchange went the
following way
uh yeah when i'm talking to the tv
camera i'm not going to wear a mask and
all of us have been immunized
so it would make us feel better you're
welcome to
step away if you like
the whole point of a vaccine cdc
guidance
is what we're following what happened
after that we did not see on camera
well that that particular camera man
went and left and he decided he didn't
want to be at the press conference
that's fine
he's welcome to make that choice you
know at some point it is a little silly
i i gotta say if you turn on the tv on
any given day and watch
say the white house press conference
with jen saki she hasn't worn a mask a
single day and you didn't see any
petulant reporters
throwing a fit and running screaming out
of the room it's particularly absurd
when every senator standing there has
been vaccinated and
and at some point it just becomes
theater it just becomes
a virtue signal as people wear two three
four masks
listen i'm not someone who says never
wear a mask i think you should use
common sense precautions
but but people have gotten pretty crazy
about this stuff senator thank you for
your time
uh we went through a lot we'll see what
we get today thank you ted cruz take
care god